a Harvard educated mathematician turned
serial bomber between 1978 and 1995 Ted
Kaczynski launched a bombing campaign
across the US that killed three people
and injured two dozen more his
self-professed motive was halting the
advance of modern technology and Society
all planned from a secluded Shack in
rural Montana he would hand deliver or
mail bombs to various victims including
an advertising executive an airline
president and a computer scientist the
FBI didn't know who he was for years the
FBI the other agencies involved are
working on this with as much diligence
as I've ever seen in an investigation
the only clue to his identity was this
sketch made after a witness saw him
planting a bomb his attacks put the
nation on edge and dominated media
coverage another bombing is making the
news tonight it's even brought air
travel to a halt on the west coast and
July 1995. in September of that same
Year kaczynski's brother recognized his
writing style in a Manifesto published
in a newspaper and alerted the FBI it
wouldn't have been right to allow him to
uh to hurt anyone else
he had to be stopped Kaczynski was
arrested in 1996.
in sentenced to life in prison two years
later
he was transferred to the medical center
of a federal prison in 2021 where he was
found dead on Saturday Alex beard Al
Jazeera